Tung tương, người trụ tịch thượng Việt Mỹ, tung tương miếng đôi trọng Việt dẫn,
quyền hiện định của mình với tư cách tổng tư lạnh và người đứng đầu nhánh hành pháp để ra lạnh hành động.
Đồng tư cho biết báo cáo được định chính phu hợp bối đạo lột quyền hạn xin trang,
nhằm đảm bảo của ổ được thương tiên đầy đủ.
Tung tù trăm nhìn mạnh, có cuộc không kích nhà vợ iran được tự thiện,
nhằm bảo vệ quân nhân Mỹ trong khu vực bảo vệ lãnh thủ Mỹ,
thúc nổi lấy an ninh Quốc gia, bảo đàn tự do hàng 2 qua yêu gian Homost,
và cùng cố quên tự vệ tập thế của các lòng mình trong đó có Isrine,
tổ tổng miếng cho rằng,
khiến chứ thệ sắc định tòa mộng sạch vi và thư ra,
của các bạn lộn cứng sự cần thiết.
Chứ nhìn con ngại về một cuộc chiến không hộn kết với iran,
bộ chưởng trên trang nghĩ biết hệ xa khẳng định,
trên sĩnh nhằm vợ iran không phải một cuộc gian dự vô thì hạn,
ông hết xe cuộc tiên đủ,
cậu tấn công của Mỹ và iran không nhằm được định thầy đủ trên đủ.
Chên tự biệt, Mỹ vô hợp với Isrine,
tí tự của cuộc tấn công rất giộn phải iran.
Hơn một nghiên hai chân năm 1 mục tiêu đã bị tính tình công
chỉ cho phòng của Mỹ tạm dự đủ tiên,
bao gồm các trung tâm trởi vì và kiểm soát,
các trình địa tư lửa đảm,
tạo chiến và tổng ngầm của hại của iran,
cũng có vệ chỉ tư lửa trăm hạn.
Chồng tư bù mấy nhất,
ngoại trưởng Mỹ và có rub yô bài tỏ tình tưởng,
Mỹ có tự đặt được các mục tiêu ở iran
mà không cần lực lực chi bộ.